so you were in like a horrific accident
when you're a kid and it was a truck hit
you
cement truck a bigger kind of truck how
did it bigger how did it even
how did that shape you because you've
got to beat you you had to mangled me
yeah I was a very weird shape after that
a lot of weird angles I met like
mentally and emotionally that's like
change things you're sure well no
absolutely I think like yeah I I like em
now I'm like happy that had happened
because I don't think I'd be doing what
I'm doing and it also it like gave me
the confidence that I can cuz I had to
relearn how to walk and like I couldn't
walk and it was like a two-year process
so like gain the strength back in my
legs and learn how to walk again and I
lost all the muscle and I'd shattered
everything for my knees down and so I
had to like fully relearn and that's
like very hard to do turns out and hey
you think like on paper you're like yeah
one step another step you got it you
figured it out when you were one you can
figure it out now but it was very hard
and so now I like I'm like I could do
anything when I can't but I have that
confidence but you can't that's what I
love of it I think that a lot of like
creative people have odd things that
happen to them and how they're horrible
or whatever because it kind of shaped
seen it make sure you the creative
person that you can you know make fun of
yourself like stuffed up occasion like
sure and even have like no shame or
probably you're just like I'm in it why
not I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this